el canciller mexicano renuncia con la
mira puesta en el Palacio Nacional Este
martes Marcelo ebrard anunció que
dimitirá a su cargo con el motivo de
presentar su precandidatura para hacer
El Elegido del partido oficial morena
para contender en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024 he resuelto
también y así se los transmito
solicitar y presentar mi renuncia a la
secretaría de relaciones exteriores a
partir del lunes 12 de junio a primera
hora la próxima semana
ebrard de 63 años es la actual cabeza de
las relaciones exteriores del país
Azteca y muchos lo catalogan como la
mano derecha del presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador el aún canciller ha
sido muy cercano a López Obrador desde
que ambos militaban en el partido de la
Revolución democrática PRD siendo parte
de su gabinete en el período de Obrador
como jefe de gobierno de la Ciudad de
México ya dentro del poder ejecutivo
Federal eddard ha sido El Elegido del
mandatario mexicano para representar al
país en foros y Cumbres internacionales
debido a su renuncia a salir de México
para asistir a este tipo de eventos a
pesar de Los Fuertes vínculos Obrador ha
declarado que él no intervendrá en la
elección del candidato de su partido no
es que yo voy a poner
al candidato de morena
no
no va a haber dedazo
va a ser la gente la victoria del
oficialismo en la gubernatura del Estado
de México el pasado domingo parece que
detonó el proceso interno en morena para
agilizar la elección de un candidato
presidencial la dirigencia del partido
prevé que el 11 de junio se presente la
fórmula en la que se elegirá el
candidato una contienda en la que parece
que Marcelo ebrard y la jefa de gobierno
de la capital Claudia sheinbaum son los
favoritos para ir por la grande